feel like this is something that has  actually been talked about  you know what this is this is i've  emected for humans you want a nobel  prize as an antiviral and this is  inhalable or these are the tablets  steroids  so let me show you  i was gonna do this anyways earlier  see this see this voucher you see this  bill gates i'm gonna kill those prions  you murderers you're hitting with a bio  weapon you monster you want to suppress  me you want to kill me you son of a you  damn demon you think i'm easy to kill  ya damn monster  that's a hell of a plug for topo find  that right double prize winning or  humans no bill prize money for humans  nobel prize winning for humans nobel  prize winning for you you know if it  weren't for the  not a beer i thought it was  if it weren't for the movements that  actually can't be caught by a 60 frame  rate right um  everything you just said is entirely  right